hmm
hello happy halloween
here we are
i'm on sky right now in the northwest of
scotland
and the wind is howling and whistling
and occasionally screaming and the rain
is pattering
and there's logs
burning in the fireplace and
i'm here to read to you
because it's halloween and because
sometimes it's
so much easier to be scared
of little things that we can leave
when they're over than to be scared
of the world outside
which we cannot leave
or at least not leave and come back
so
wonderful wedding hat
doesn't get worn a lot
and
the first thing i want to read you
um it is as a lot of my short stories
are right now
in this hefty great tome
with my head exploding on the cover in
the uk edition
um called the neil gaiman reader
and this is a story called
click clack the rattle bag
before you take me up to bed will you
tell me a story
do you actually need me to take you up
to bed
i asked the boy he thought for a moment
then with intense seriousness
yes actually i think i do it's because
of
i've finished my homework and so it's my
bedtime and i am a bit scared
not very scared just a bit
but it is a very big house and lots of
times the lights don't work
and it's sort of dark i reached over
and tousled his hair i can understand
that
i said it is a very big old house
he nodded we were in the kitchen where
it was light
and warm i put down my magazine on the
kitchen table
what kind of story would you like me to
tell you
well he said thoughtfully
i don't think it should be too scary
because then when i go up to bed
i would just be thinking about monsters
the whole time
but if it isn't just a little bit scary
then i won't be interested
and you make up scary stories don't you
i know she says that's what you do
well she exaggerates i write stories yes
nothing that's really been published yet
though and i write lots of different
kinds of stories
but you do write scary stories
yes the boy looked up at me
from the shadows by the door where he
was waiting
do you know any stories about click
clack the rattle bag
i don't think so those are the best
sorts of stories
do they tell them at your school
he shrugged sometimes
what's a click clack the rattlebag story
he was a precocious child and was
unimpressed by his sister's boyfriend's
ignorance you could see it on his face
everybody knows them i don't
i said trying not to smile
he looked at me as if he was trying to
decide whether or not i was pulling his
leg
he said i think maybe
you should take me up to my bedroom and
then you can tell me a story before i go
to sleep
but probably it should be a not scary
story because
i'll be up in my bedroom then and it's
actually a bit dark up there too
i said shall i leave a note for your
sister
telling her where we are you can
but you'll hear when they get back the
front door
is very slammy we walked out of the warm
and cozy kitchen into the hallway of the
big house
where it was chilly and drafty and dark
i flicked the light switch but the hall
remained dark
the bulbs gone the boys said
that always happens our eyes
adjusted to the shadows the moon was
almost
full and blue white moonlight shone in
through the high windows on the
staircase
down into the hall we'll be all right
i said yes said the boy
soberly i am very glad you're here
he seemed less precocious now his hand
found mine and he held onto my fingers
comfortably trustingly as if he'd known
me all his life
i felt responsible and adult
i did not know if the feeling i had for
his sister
who was my girlfriend was love
not yet but i liked that the child
treated me
as one of the family i felt like his big
brother
i stood taller and if there was
something unsettling about the empty
house
i would not have admitted it for worlds
the stairs creaked beneath the
threadbare stair carpet
click clacks said the boy
are the best monsters ever
are they from television i don't think
so
i don't think any people know where they
come from mostly they come from the dark
good place for a monster to come yes
we walked along the upper corridor in
the shadows moving from patch of
moonlight
to patch of moonlight it really was a
big house
i wished i had a flashlight
they come from the dark said the boy
holding on to my hand
i think probably they're made of dark
and they come in when you don't pay
attention
that's when they come in and then they
take you back to their
not nests what's a word that's like
nests but not house
no it's not a house lair
he was silent then
i think that's the word yes lair
he squeezed my hand he stopped talking
right so they take the people who don't
pay attention back to their lair
and what do they do then you're monsters
do they suck all the blood of you out of
you
like vampires he snorted
vampires don't suck all the blood out of
you
they only drink a little bit just to
keep them going and
you know flying around click-clacks
are much scarier than vampires
i'm not scared of vampires i told him me
neither i'm not scared of vampires
either
do you want to know what click clacks do
they
drink you said the boy
like a coke coke is
very bad for you said the boy
if you put a tooth in coke in the
morning it will be dissolved into
nothing that's how bad coke is for you
and why you must always clean your teeth
every night i'd heard the coke story as
a boy and
had been told as an adult that it wasn't
true
but was certain that a lie which
promoted dental hygiene
was a good lie and i let it pass
click clacks drink you said the boy
first they bite you
and then you go all ichi inside and all
your meat and all your brains and
everything except your bones and your
skin turns into a wet
milk shaky stuff and then the click
clack
sucks it out through the holes where
your eyes used to be
that's disgusting i told him
did you make it up we'd reach the last
flight of stairs
all the way into the big house no
i can't believe you kids make up stuff
like that
you didn't ask me about the rattle bag
he said right
what's the rattle bag well he said
sagely soberly a small voice from the
darkness beside me
once you're just bones and skin they
hang you up on a hook
and you rattle in the wind
so what do these click clacks look like
even as i asked him i wished i could
take the question back
and leave it unasked i thought
huge spidery creatures like the one in
the shower this morning
i'm afraid of spiders i was relieved
when the boys said
they looked like what you aren't
expecting what you aren't paying
attention to
we were climbing wooden steps now
i held on to the railing on my left held
his hand with my right as he walked
beside me
it smelled like dust and old wood that
high in the house
the boy's tread was certain though even
though the moonlight was scarce
do you know what story you're going to
tell me to put me to bed
he asked like i said it doesn't actually
have to be scary
and not really maybe you could tell me
about this evening
tell me what you did well that won't
make much of a story for you
my girlfriend just moved into a new
place on the edge of town
she inherited it from an aunt or someone
it's very big and very old i'm going to
spend my first
night with her tonight so i've been
waiting for an
hour or so for her and her housemates to
come back with the wine
and an indian takeaway see
said the boy there was that precocious
amusement again
but all kids can be insufferable
sometimes
when they think they know something you
don't it's probably good for them
you know all that but you don't think
you just let your brain fill in the gaps
he pushed open the door to the attic
room
it was perfectly dark now but the
opening door disturbed the air
and i heard things rattle gently like
dry bones in thin
bags in the slight wind
click clack
click
like that i would have pulled away then
if i could but small firm
fingers pulled me forward unrelentingly
into the dark
so i was click clack the rattle bag
and that's the first of the things i
want to read tonight
and the second
isn't by me at all and this was actually
in a lot of ways why i thought it would
be fun
to do a reading it's by aguero
and it seemed just a little bit
too for the appropriate we're in right
now
it's called the mask of the red death
the red death had long devastated the
country
no pestilence had ever been so fatal
or so hideous blood was its avatar
and its seal the redness and the horror
of
blood there were sharp pains
and sudden dizziness and then profuse
bleeding at the pores with dissolution
the scarlet stains upon the body and
especially upon the face of the victim
with a pest ban
which shut him out from the a and from
the sympathy of his fellow men
and the whole seizure progress and
determination of the disease
were the incidents of half an hour
but the prince prospero was happy
and dauntless and sagacious
when his dominions were half depopulated
he summoned to his presence a thousand
hail and light-hearted friends from
among the knights and dames of his court
and these retired to the deep seclusion
of one of his castellated abbeys
this was an extensive and magnificent
structure
the creation of the prince's own
eccentric yet
august taste a strong and lofty wall
girdled it in this wall had gates of
iron
the courtiers having entered brought
furnaces and
messy hammers and welded the bolts
they resolved to leave means neither of
ingress
nor egress to the sudden impulses of
despair
or of frenzy from within
the abbey was amply provisioned
with such precautions the courtiers
might bid
violence to contagion the external world
could take
care of itself in the meantime
it was folly to grieve or to think
the prince had provided all the
appliances of pleasure
there were buffoons there were
improvisatory
there were ballet dancers there were
musicians there was beauty there was
wine
all these and security were within
without was the red death
it was towards the close of the fifth or
sixth month of his seclusion and while
the pestilence raged most furiously
abroad
that the prince prospero entertained his
thousand friends
at a masked ball of the most unusual
magnificence
it was a value a scene that masquerade
but first let me tell of the rooms in
which it was held
these were seven an imperial suite
in many palaces however such sweets form
a long
and straight vista while the folding bus
slide back
nearly to the walls and either hand so
that the view of the whole extent
is scarcely impeded here the case was
very different
as might have been expected from the
duke's love of the
bizarre the apartments
were so irregularly disposed that the
vision
embraced but little more than one at a
time
there was a sharp turn at every 20 or 30
yards
and at each turn a novel effect
to the right and left in the middle of
each wall a tall and
narrow gothic window looked out upon a
closed corridor
which pursued the windings of the suite
these windows for a stained glass
whose color varied in accordance with
the prevailing
hue of the decorations of the chamber
into which it opened
that at the east an extremity was hung
for example in
and vividly blue were its windows the
second chamber was
purple in its ornaments and tapestries
and here the pains
were purple the third was green
throughout
and so were the casements the fourth was
furnished and lighted with orange
the fifth with white the sixth with
violet
the seventh apartment was closely
shrouded
in black velvet tapestries that hung
all over the ceiling and down the walls
falling in heavy folds upon a carpet of
the same
material and hue but in this chamber
only
the color of the windows failed to
correspond
with the decorations the pains here
was scarlet a deep blood
color now in no one of the seven
apartments was there any lamp
or candelabrum amid the profusion of
golden ornaments
that lay scattered to and fro depended
from the roof
there was no light of any kind emanating
from lamp or candle within the suite of
chambers
but in the corridors that followed the
suite they stood
opposite to each window a heavy tripod
bearing abrasion of fire that projected
its rays through the tinted glass and so
glaringly
illumined the room and thus
were produced a multitude of gordy and
fantastic appearances
but in the western or black chamber
the effect of the fire light that
streamed upon the dark hangings
through the blood tinted pains was
ghastly in the
extreme and put so wild a look upon the
countenances of those who entered
that there were few of the company bold
enough to set foot within its precincts
at all
it was in this apartment also
that there stood against the western
wall a gigantic
clock of ebony its pendulum
swung to and fro with a dull
heavy monotonous clang
and when the minute hand made the
circuit of the face
and the hour was to be stricken they
came from the brazen lungs of the clock
a sound which was clear and loud and
deep
and exceedingly musical but of so
peculiar a note
an emphasis that at each lapse of an
hour
the musicians of the orchestra were
constrained to pause
momentarily in their performance
to hearken to the sound and thus the
waltzer's perforce
ceased their evolutions and there was a
brief disconcert of the whole
gay company and while the chimes of the
clock yet rang
it was observed that the giddiest grew
pale
and the more aged and sedate passed
their hands over their brows
as if in confused reverie or meditation
and when the echoes had fully ceased a
light laughter at once pervaded the
assembly
the musicians looked at each other and
smiled as if at their own
nervousness and folly and made
whispering vows into the other that the
next
chiming of the clock should produce in
them no similar emotion
and then after the lapse of 60 minutes
which embrace 3600 seconds of the time
that flies there came yet another
chiming of the clock
and then with the same disconcert
and tremulousness and meditation
as before but
in spite of these things it was a gay
and magnificent revel
the tastes of the duke were peculiar he
had a fine eye for colours and effects
he disregarded the decorah of mere
fashion
his plans were bold and fiery and his
conceptions
glowed with barbaric lustre there are
some who would have thought him mad
his followers felt that he was not
it was necessary to hear and see and
touch him to be
sure that he was not
he had directed in great part the
movable embellishments
of the seven chambers upon occasion of
this grand
theft and it was his own guiding taste
which had given character to the
macarenas
be sure they were grotesque
there were much glare and glitter and
peacock and phantasm
much of what has been since seen in
hernani
there were arabesque figures with
unsuited limbs and appointments
there were delirious fancies such as the
madman fashions
there were much of the beautiful much of
the wanton
much of the bizarre something of the
terrible
and not a little of that which might
have excited
disgust to and fro in the seven chambers
they're stalked in fact
a multitude of dreams and these the
dreams
arrived in and about taking hue from the
rooms and caught
the wild music of the orchestra to seem
as the echo of their steps
and along this strikes the ebony clock
which stands in the hall of the velvet
and then for a moment all is still
and all is silent save the voice of the
clock
the dreams are stiff frozen as they
stand
but the echoes of the chime die away
they have endured but an instant and a
light half-subviewed laughter floats
after them as they depart
and now again the music swells and the
dreams
live and drive to and fro
more merrily than ever taking hue from
the minted windows
through which stream the rays from the
tripods
but to the chamber which lies most
westwardly of the seven
there are now none of the maskers who
venture
for the night is waning away and there
flows a ruddier light
through the blood-colored pains and the
blackness of the sable drapery
appalls and to him whose foot falls upon
the sable carpet
there comes from the near clock of ebony
a muffled peel more solemnly emphatic
than any which reaches their ears who
indulged in the more remote
gaieties of the other apartments
but these other apartments were densely
bid and in them beat
feverishly the heart of life and the
revel went
whirlingly on until at length they
commenced the sounding of midnight upon
the clock
and then the music ceased as i have told
and the evolutions of the waltzes were
quieted
and they were uneasy cessation of all
things as before
but now there were 12 strokes to be
sounded by the
bell of the clock and thus it happened
perhaps but more of thought crept
with more of time into the meditations
of the thoughtful among those who
reveled
and thus too it happened perhaps
before the last echoes of the last chime
had utterly sunk into silence
there were many individuals in the crowd
who had found leisure
to become aware of the presence of a
masked
figure which had arrested the attention
of no single individual before
and the of this new presence having
spread itself
whisperingly around there arose at
length from the whole company
a buzz or murmur
expressive of disapprobation and
surprise
then finally of terror
of horror and of disgust
in an assembly of phantasm such as i
have painted
it may well be supposed that no ordinary
appearance could have excited such
sensation
in truth the masquerade license of the
night was nearly unlimited
but the figure in question had out herod
and gone beyond the bounds of even the
prince's indefinite decorum
there are chords in the hearts of the
most reckless
which cannot be touched without emotion
even with the
utterly lost to whom life and death
are equally jests there are matters
of which no jest can be made the whole
company indeed
seemed now deeply to feel that in the
costume and bearing
of the stranger neither wit nor priority
existed the figure was tall and gaunt
and shrouded from head
in the habilaments of the grave
the mask which concealed the visage was
made
so nearly to resemble the countenance of
a stiffened
corpse the closest scrutiny
must have had difficulty in detecting
the cheat
and yet all this might have been endured
if not approved by the mad revelers
around
but the mama had gone so far as to
assume the type
of the red death his vesture
was dabbled in blood and his broad
brow with all the features of the face
was besprinkled
with the scarlet horror
when the eyes of the prince prospero
fell upon this
spectral image which with a slow
and solemn movement as if more fully to
sustain its role
stalked to and fro
among the waltzes he was seen to be
convulsed
in the first moment with a strong
shudder
either of terror or distaste
but in the next his brow reddened with
rage
who dares he demanded hoarsely
of the courtiers who stood near him who
dares insult us with this
blasphemous mockery sees him and unmask
him
that we may know whom we have to hang at
sunrise from the battlements
it was in the eastern or blue chamber in
which stood
the prince prospero as he uttered these
words
they rang throughout the seven rooms
loudly and clearly
for the prince was a bold and robust man
and the music had become hushed
at the waving of his hand
it was in the blue room where stood the
prince
with a group of pale courtiers by his
side
at first as he spoke there was a slight
rushing movement of this group
in the direction of the intruder who at
the moment was also near at hand
and now with a deliberate and stately
step
made closer approach to the speaker but
from a certain nameless or
with which the mad assumptions of them
had inspired the whole party
oh i found none who put forth hand to
seize him
so that unimpeded he passed within a
yard
of the prince's person
and while the vast assembly as if with
one impulse
shrank from the centers of the room to
the walls
he made his way uninterruptedly
but with the same solemn and measured
step
which had distinguished him from the
first
through the blue chamber to the purple
through the purple to the green
through the green to the orange through
this again to the white
and even thence to the violet a decided
movement had been made
to arrest him it was then however that
the prince prospero
maddening with rage and the shame of his
own
momentary cowardice rushed hurriedly
through the six
chambers while none followed him on
account of a deadly terror
that had seized upon all he bore aloft a
drawn dagger
and had approached in rapid impetuocity
to within three or four feet of the
retreating figure when the latter having
attained the extremity of the velvet
apartment
turned suddenly and confronted
his pursuer there was a sharp cry
and the dagger dropped gleaming upon the
sable carpet
upon which instantly afterwards
fell prostrate in death
the prince prospero
then summoning the wild courage of
despair
a throng of the revelers that once threw
themselves into the black apartment and
seizing the mama whose tall figure stood
erect and motionless within the shadow
of the ebony clock gasped in
unutterable horror at finding the grave
sermons and corpse-like
masks which they handle with so violent
a rudeness
untenanted by any tangible form
and now was acknowledged the presence
of the red death he had come
like a thief in the night and one by one
dropped the revelers in the
blood-bedewed halls of their revel
and died each in the despairing posture
of his fall
and the life of the ebony clock
went out with that to the last of the
gay
and the flames of the tripods expired
and darkness and decay
and the red death held illimitable
dominion
over all
there that was a girl and pose story
and i thought i'd end
with something more homely
more cheerful more personal
especially in this storm
this began with me wondering
what the scariest place in the world is
i was born in portsmouth
and grew up
there's a small child my grandparents
in south sea and i go down to the beach
and it always seemed to me that the
beaches
of english seaside towns out of season
are the scariest places of all
but then again there are places that are
scarier
this is called my last
land lady
my last landlady she was nothing like
you
her rooms were damp the breakfasts were
unpleasant
oily eggs leathery sausages a baked
orange sludge
of beans her face could have curdled
beans
she was not kind you strike me as a kind
person
i hope your world is kind
by which i mean i've heard we see the
world
not as it is but as we are
a saint sees a world of saints a killer
sees only murderers and victims
i see the dead my landlady told me
she would not willingly walk upon the
beach for it was littered with weapons
huge hand-fitting rocks each ripe
for striking she only had a little money
in her tiny purse
she said but they would take the notes
oily from her fingers
and leave the purse tucked underneath
the stone
and the water she said hold anyone under
chill salt water gray and brown heavy as
sin
all ready to drag you away
children went like that so easily
in the sea when they were surplus to
requirements
or had learned awkward facts they might
be inclined to pass on
to those who would listen there were
people on the west
pier the night it burned she said
the curtains were dusty lace and blocked
each town grimed window
sea view that was a laugh
the morning she saw me twitch her
curtains to see if it was properly
raining she wrapped my knuckles
mr maroney she said in this house
we do not look at the sea through the
windows
it brings bad luck she said
people come to the beach to forget their
problems it's what we do
is the english do you chop your
girlfriend up because she's pregnant and
you're worried what the wife would say
if she found out or you poison the
banker you're sleeping with
for the insurance marry a dozen men in a
dozen little seaside towns
margate torquay lord love them but
why must they stand so still
when i asked her who who stood so still
she told me it was none of my beeswax
and to be sure to be
out of the house between midday and four
as the char was coming and i would be
underfoot
and in the way
i had been there three weeks i was
looking for permanent digs
the other guests were loveless folk on
holiday and did not care if this was
hove
or hell we'd eat our dreary eggs
together in the morning
i'd see them promenade if the day was
fine or huddle under awnings if it
rained
my landlady cared only that they were
out of the house
until tea time
a retired dentist from edge bastion
down for a week of loneliness and
drizzle by the sea
would nod at me over breakfast or if we
passed
on the seafront the bathroom
was down the hall i was up in the night
i saw him in his dressing gown
i saw him knock upon her door i saw it
open
he went in nothing more to tell
my last landlady was there at breakfast
bright and cheery
she said the dentist had left early due
to a death
in the family she told the truth
that night the rain rattled my windows
a week passed and it was time
i told my landlady i'd found a place and
we'll be moving on and paid the rent
that night she gave me a glass of
whiskey and then
another and said i had always been her
favorite
and that she was a woman of needs a
flower
ripe for plucking and she smiled
and it was the whiskey made me nod and
think she was perhaps a witch less
sour of face and form
and so i knocked upon her door that
night
she owed it i remember the whiteness of
her skin
the whiteness of a gown i can't forget
mr marone she whispered
i reached for her and that was forever
that the channel was cold
and sort wet and she filled my pockets
with
rocks to keep me under so when they find
me
if they find me i could be anyone
crab eaten flesh and sea washed bones
and all
i think i shall like it here in my new
digs
and you have made me welcome
you have all made me feel so welcome
how many of us are there here
i see us but i cannot count
we cluster on the beach and stare at the
light in the uppermost room of her house
we see the curtains twitch we see a
white face
glaring through the grime
she looks afraid as if one gray day
we might start up the beach towards her
to rebuke her for her lack of
hospitality
to tear her for her bad breakfasts
and her sour holidays
we stand so still
why must we stand
so still
there
that's my last landlady
and it's the last thing i'm going to do
in the reading thank you for spending
this 40 minutes with me
as the wind howled and the rain lashed
i hope your halloweens
are marvelous things and that all the
ghosts
that come to visit you tonight are kind
be good to each other good night
you